hi I'm Evan cry Michael and I received a
note from one of my for moderators craig
brown braids and he asked if i would do
a testimonial for him and I thought
instead of writing something now to
create this quick video for you guys to
watch Trent I've known for a number of
years and he's been a moderator a very
active member in our entrepreneur forums
and it's a community we've created for
entrepreneurs to will to share ideas and
help each other out and trend started as
a very active member was adding a lot of
great content sharing a lot of unique
ideas and sharing his perspective and
really trying to help people up and
that's one thing i really respect admire
about trends is he's always trying to
help people out and give them the best
advice you can and not building anything
back even if there's no direct benefit
from him and really wants to help the
people who are part of our community and
we try to be a really helpful community
of entrepreneurs and he's a big part of
that he then became a moderator and has
some responsibilities within the
community now and be able to moderates
in posts and reject new post coming in
and new members etc and he's in addition
to that always trying to think of ways
to make the community better even though
again there's no there's no interest for
him apart from being part of a better
community but is always trying to share
ideas and how they'll form could be
better how we could implement new ideas
to make our you know systems run
smoother and sharing everything from
marketing ideas to you know online
strategies to you know packing
operations ideas and I really value the
input that that trend has both from you
know the help our community members and
leave such great feedback for people and
also me personally as a business owner
be able to get his feedback on how my
businesses can grow and the strategies
he's given us have work they've been
great and a really grateful you trying
to to have you part of our community and
visa
active involved so for every of anybody
considering working with trentman
definitely give them two thumbs up and
should definitely no take that next step
in and you'll have a great time working
with them trying to hope that helps and
we'll see you soon
you